but yeah I mean I don't what I don't
like to get too deep into like you know
the biz the politics or the politics or
the business yeah my car I'll see you
around taking a sword out of my car
[Laughter]
it's just grounds for immediate
termination well it's so funny because
last night I saw a girl at in the belly
room and she was new at comedy she'd
done it maybe two or three times and she
hadn't okay set okay audience it was a
bring her room I think and they laughed
at her and you could see her walk
offstage and see you mean yeah
believably is going right right and the
change right and and the future I mean
all of it right in her face
right and I giggled to myself guy go
that's gonna go away real fast but it's
like so when he opened Micro goes I'll
see you on the circuit right I get what
it is it's like him trying to go I'm a
comic - yeah I've got you know wrong
he's happy I won the same thing but I
want to tell that person no no you're
not
you know and I've ever talked about how
through that glass through a class oh my
god dude there's this girl
you throw a glass at a girl no I'll get
the wall of the in the hallway this girl
walks down the hall home like I can't
believe I talked about this a long time
ago yeah she walks down and she like
does get out of the way to me I'm
standing there with a drink okay like a
Coke or something I go I'm looking on
the way oh yeah your mind she goes I'm a
comic alright I go I go I'm a comedian
as well I said yeah but you know we're
both comics you just get out of the way
like she's walking through or whatever
yeah so go you
at the whole hole you performed here
she's got three times you know and I got
okay I'm gonna show you the kind of
power I have I go stand back she step
back I took the glass
I threw it against the wall and
shattered and then Brett middle calm
brenton middle comb sweep tit in the
back right away and I go there's nothing
they can do about it what is it
Ridge wallet my favorite ad in the world